this is an absolutely desperate scene
you can see people who are elderly who
are frail who are unable to cross
themselves having to be carried over
this tiny little plank there's a real
urgency here amongst the soldiers and
those who are trying to get them over
because they don't know how long this
lull
in the fighting is going to continue
we've heard a bit of um shelling but
it's mostly coming from this side and
there's clearly a huge number of people
waiting still anxious to get over we
understand from the ukrainian officials
there are about 4 000 people or so
trapped not just in the urban but coming
from butcher and hostimal so
there's a a real
frantic
uh urgency about trying to get them over
and out of of this area which has come
under attack several times over the last
few days
the incredible scene there are dozens of
people like this man who are having to
be held and taken over a really
precarious rickety bridge and do it
slowly because you can't have too many
people on that bridge at one time or
else it will just snap and they try to
do this quickly before the firing starts
again